[Musique]
ce sont les héritiers d'une tradition
vieille de plusieurs milliers d'années
selon la mythologie hindoue les dieux
pratiquait déjà cet art martial sur de
l'argile rouge
aujourd'hui les meilleurs lutteurs du
pays sont formés dans ce tas l'hymne du
sud de l'inde
dans ce gymnase qui ressemble à un
temple ils s'entraînent sous le regard
d'une légende vivante du coup jacques
krabal gay le maître des lieux s'appelle
dadou tu rigoles et plusieurs fois
champion d'un des pertes sur les gens
efficacement
le tell him c'est notre temps cette
argile rouge c'est notre mère
devons la respecter et la traiter comme
une déesse
si les lutteurs se concentre sur le coup
ch'tis de la même façon que laisser un
doute pratiquer la méditation
si leur concentration est totale l'étude
raccorderont la victoire
[Musique]
colas pour quatre cent mille habitants
dans le sud de l'inde
la ville dort encore au moment où les
premières lumières du talent il s'allume
il est 4h30 du matin c'est le début de
la journée d'entraînement pour les
soixante quinze pensionnaires du gymnase
allez réveiller vous et réveiller ceux
qui dorment encore
ramasser vos affaires dépêchez-vous
premier rituel de la journée au talent
hymne la prière hanuman le dieu des
lutteurs
nous te prions hanuman plus rapide que
le vent et l'esprit toi qui contrôlent
ton corps et essence à la perfection
fils du vent chef des troupes singes
auprès de toi nous trouvons refuge
les apprenti lutteur à valence 8 5 km de
footing dans les rues encore désertes de
la ville
continuer au même rythme
ne ralentissait pas
freddy pas 15 ans cela fait deux ans
qu'il se réveille tous les matins de
cette façon
se lever tôt c'était vraiment dur quand
je suis arrivé
mais je me suis fait
aujourd'hui j'y pense même plus c'est la
routine vasella
mais maintenant j'aime ça
[Musique]
autale him on prépare la cada l'endroit
le plus sacré pour tous les auteurs de
coups ch'tis
un carré de 6 mètres sur 6 ou l'argile
et religieusement retourné deux fois par
jour selon la médecine traditionnelle
indienne la terre doit respirer pour
conserver son pouvoir guérisseur
non
l'entraînement dans la cada commence
pour pradeep à partir de 6h du matin
sous le regard du dieu à la tête de
singe anoman qu'il faut honorer avant
chaque combat
les règles du coup ch'tis sont très
proches de celles de la lutte gréco
romaine mais beaucoup plus anciennes
les jeunes lutteurs sont ici pour
apprendre les centaines de prises et de
mouvement nécessaire pour battre
l'adversaire en lui plaquant les épaules
au sol
pradeep est un grand espoir du talent
hymne comme d'autres jeunes il a été
repéré dans un tournoi local avant de
venir ici
ce tte lima produit plus de champions de
cousty que n'importe quel autre en un
parce qu'ici c'est dur c'est rigoureux
c'est exigeant
cette réputation effraie les jeunes
lutteurs qui veulent venir chez nous
mais ils savent qu'il n'ya pas d'autre
endroit où s'entraîner aussi bien
qu'avant
[Musique]
dès l'âge de 12 ou 13 ans les
pensionnaires du talent ils sont livrés
à eux mêmes entre la routine de
l'entraînement et la préparation des
repas
pas de cuisinière les femmes ne sont pas
autorisés
tout est préparé au réfectoire selon
leurs règles de vie communes des
lutteurs ici l'espace personnel de
pradeep tient dans ces deux mâles voilà
mes affaires de sport mon survêtement en
jean
ici j'ai du sucre
et là des épices
tous les matins on prend un grand verre
de temps die au réveil qu'une petit
déjeuner des légumes de la grèce d eux
est un peu d'eau et des épices avec
aussi des fruits des bananes et des
pommes
ensuite on se voit un litre de lait et
après les séances d'entraînement on
mange encore un peu quelques fruits secs
et du temps d'heinz il n'est que le soir
on a droit de veto et du poulet avec un
corps du tandem
le temps die la potion magique
d'éditeurs aussi vieille que ce sport
des amendes et des noix de cajou broyer
auquel on rajoute de l'eau du lait et
des épices un concentré d'énergie que
les lutteurs boivent après chaque
entraînement après chaque repas
mais amandes et noix de cajou sont ici
des produits de luxe qui pèse lourd sur
les frais d'hébergement
chaque pensionnaire coûte 100 euros par
mois à sa famille ni
[Musique]
le gouvernement nous donne un peu
d'argent mais c'est pas suffisant
heureusement mes parents sont fous de
couches ils font des efforts pour que je
devienne un grand lutteur
les jeunes rêvent de se faire un
palmarès comme celui de sa guerre une
des stars du talent hymne
quand il rentre sur la cada les autres
lutteurs arrêtent leurs entraînements
[Applaudissements]
personne ne veut manquer le cours
magistral du maître allez maraj lève toi
que tu as pris hier anouma n'est pas de
battre contre sa gare
[Musique]
à 25 ans il a déjà remporté plusieurs
tournois importants il ne lui manque que
le titre de champion d'indy
c'est bon c'est bon on laisse le
maintenant
quand je rentre sur la cada mon
adversaire est mon ennemi il est là pour
me battre
alors je n'ai pas de respect pour
c'est comme ça le gauche si c'est dur
c'est dangereux ça demande beaucoup
d'efforts
mais au bout c'est une chance de se
faire un nom et une réputation
à coup là pour le coup ch'tis est une
religion les lutteurs des moines
cloîtrés dans leur talent hymne
leur seule sortie sont réservés aux
compétitions un tournoi doit justement
être organisée pour marquer la fin d'une
semaine de fêtes religieuses
sa guerre et pradeep se doivent d'y
briller
avant le tournoi les entraîneurs les ont
autorisés à rendre visite à leur famille
tous les deux sont originaires de la
même région à plusieurs heures de bus de
la ville
la pause dans leur vie de lutter sera
courte
retour impératif le soir même
on ne retourne chez nous que trois ou
quatre fois dans l'année pour les
grandes occasions seulement
le salut ne laisse jamais sortir très
longtemps et comme on habite loin c'est
compliqué de rentrer chez eux
c'est vrai que c'est dur de rester aussi
longtemps loin de chez soi
mais c'est comme ça on n'a pas le choix
les deux lutteurs rendent visite à la
famille de pradeep dans un village où on
est lutteurs de père en fils
tous appartiennent à la caste des
chatteries ya les guerriers de la
hiérarchie sociale inde où
le père de pradeep est un ancien
champion de couches ti c'est grâce à ces
médailles gagnées sur les acca date du
pays que cette famille de paysans a
gagné sa reconnaissance sociale
j'étais un lutteur très dur très rapide
la plupart de mes adversaires avaient
peur de moi parce que j'avais une
technique spéciale qui les déconcentrer
les faisait tomber
il n'en avait qu'un et qu'ils n'avaient
pas peur parce qu'il était aussi bon que
moi techniquement oui j'en ai entendu
parler il s'appelait patel
quand il y avait des compétitions
nationales tous les autres redoutait de
se mesurer à lui
à la fin de ma carrière on m'a proposé
du travail dans les services publics
comme la police ou les chemins de fer
j'étais l'aînée de ma famille je ne
pouvais pas le laisser tomber j'espère
que pradeep deviendra un bon lutteur et
qu'on lui proposera un travail bien payé
pour se construire une vie meilleure
dans cette région rurale des champions
sont célébrés comme des héros
en plein centre une statue rend même
hommage à tous ceux qui ont participé
aux épreuves olympiques de lutte loin de
l'inde moderne a tiré par l'occident
colas pour reste fidèle à une culture
une tradition dont le coût ch'tis est un
élément essentiel
samedi jour de tournoi dabitch goulet
avant les derniers hommages à nauman
ce sont les juniors qui ouvre le bal
pradeep et nerveux s'il gagne ce combat
il pourra participer aux compétitions
nationales
[Applaudissements]
en attendant son match sa guerre
encourage le benjamin du tas libre
je suis sûre que pradeep va gagner son
adversaire et bon lutteur mais il s'est
beaucoup entraîné dernièrement
[Musique]
c'est bon j'ai l'impression qu'ils
commencent à prendre le dessus
il faudrait qu'il le mette au sol
bordeaux
allait pradeep vase il peut le trouver
le combat est serré l'adversaire de
pradeep un an de plus il a déjà remporté
un tournoi
ne prédit prend l'ascendant jusqu'à la
blessure
son adversaire s'est cassé une dent sur
une mise au sol
le combat est arrêté
votre vainqueur le match nul à un goût
amer
oui je suis content de mon match même si
ça s'est fini sur un nul mais bon je
veux gagner
c'est maintenant au tour de meilleurs
lutteurs de te rappeler sur la cada
[Musique]
l'adversaire de sa guerre n'est pas
facile il fait vingt centimètres et
vingt kilos de plus que le champion
d'italie mme
ils se sont déjà rencontrées quatre fois
sa guerre plus technique et plus rapide
n'a jamais perdu
mais ce soir sa guerre est affaibli son
genou le fait souffrir et son adversaire
le sait
il va imposer une épreuve de force brute
[Applaudissements]
après quinze minutes de combat les deux
hommes sont exténués les positions sont
figées
c'est un match nul presque inespéré
sa guerre à résister aux assauts du
colosse mais le champion est orgueilleux
là je me sens encore très nerveux je ne
suis pas content du tout de mon match il
faut que je sois meilleur pour les
prochaines compétitions
je vais vraiment devoir l'entraîneur
[Musique]
sa guerre repart déçu vers le tas leem
le lendemain il reprendra sa vie de
moine continue en mêlée sa sueur à
l'argile rouge de la cada
[Musique]
m
dans la tente de cette gloire promise
par anuman aux lutteurs de couches qui
qui se dévoue entièrement à leur art
[Musique]